-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're
doing well tonight
and now, if you don't mind,
we are going to get to the news.
President Biden criticized
the GOP yesterday and said,
"This ain't your father's
Republican Party."
Yeah, this one definitely feels
more like your uncle's.
[ Laughter ]
President Biden also said
that next week's midterms are
the "most important election
of our lifetime,"
and that's saying something,
coming from a guy who, maybe,
voted for Lincoln?
[ Laughter ]
President Biden warned yesterday
that Republican
Senator Rick Scott wants
to cut Social Security
and Medicare, and added,
"Hot damn, boy!"
By the way, using the phrase
"Hot damn, boy,"
instantly qualifies you
for Medicare.
[ Laughter and applause ]
At a campaign stop in Wisconsin,
Republican Senator Ron Johnson
said that he is not sure
if he will accept the results
of next week's
midterm elections, and added,
"Do Democrats have something
up their sleeves?"
Have you met Democrats?
They famously have nothing
up their sleeve.
[ Laughter ]
The best they can manage is
a quarter behind the ear.
[ Laughter ]
According to a new poll,
just 10% of voters
under the age of 40
strongly approve
of President Biden,
but mostly because people
under 40
don't really feel
strongly anymore.
[ Laughter ]
Dave, your house is on fire!
"Alright, man, I don't know."
[ Laughter ]
Agriculture
Secretary Tom Vilsack
told reporters yesterday
that the country is facing
a turkey shortage.
Oh, no!
You mean we might not get
to have
the world's driest meat
this Thanksgiving?
[ Laughter ]
What's next, a shortage on the
raisins that ruin stuffing?
[ Laughter ]
Under a new pay transparency law
that took effect yesterday,
New York City employers
are now required
to disclose salary ranges
in all job listings,
which was a humiliating way
to find out Wally makes more
than me.
[ Laughter and applause ]
A fire broke out early yesterday
at New York City's
Museum of Natural History
and took about an hour
to contain.
It took so long because none
of the rescue personnel
could figure out where they were
on the free map.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Starbucks will begin offering
its holiday drink cups tomorrow.
That story again --
tomorrow marks the start
of the war on Christmas.
"Plain red?!
[ Laughter ]
Do Jesus and Santa know
about this?!"
[ Laughter ]
And, finally,
according to new reports,
staff morale at CNN is
at an all-time low
as the network undergoes
a cost-cutting overhaul.
In related news, get ready
for the new season of...
[ Laughter ]
And that was the monologue,
everybody!